[Applaudissements]
merci merci
bonjour comme ça comment ça va mon
Florian mais ça va très vite toujours
frais toujours toujours
tes frais il est là tu trouves pas vrai
merci il est là mais moi j'adore il est
là vraiment alors vraiment vraiment
bien à la maison ma chérie
le président de canal qui m'appelle là
vous inquiétez pas si on doit aller
chercher des croissances ensemble
j'expliquerai
Miss France la guerre continue à parler
ça s'arrange pas parce qu'on a une
semaine de l'élection et c'est nos amis
de gala qui nous révèlent ça cette
semaine elle a fuite femme desire
vous avez vu que elle leur a laissé un
message gala la chanteuse si vous gagnez
avec vous
vous intéressez un petit peu la Coupe du
monde
[Musique]
c'est le son de l'équipe de France
la guerre continue
c'est un magazine qui est d'ordinaire
plutôt bienveillant plutôt plutôt même
condescendant avec les personnes avec
les people là il parle de Sylvie Tellier
donc de Denise Fabre qui va prendre sa
suite et
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en fait il parle d'une ambiance glaciale
entre les deux parce que comme tu le
sais Sindy a pris la suite de Sylvie il
y a eu le traditionnel voyage en
Guadeloupe où elles sont toutes sous les
tropiques etc normalement
raconte qu'elle se sont évitées
copieusement pendant tout le séjour
elles ont fait table à part elles ont
pas pris l'ensemble la pause ensemble
pour les photographes elles ont même
évité de prendre l'avion ensemble
Delphine tu as des infos là oui oui bien
sûr
[Rires]
je vais vous dire mon ressenti des infos
des infos oui oui si on n'a pas ça bien
sûr je vais vous dire ce que j'en pense
alors non c'est important non mais
franchement c'est très important parce
qu'on le sait si le vitellier ça fait 17
ans qu'elle est là d'accord Cindy prends
sa suite pour des raisons un peu voilà
un peu politique au sein de l'État Major
de Miss France aujourd'hui à l'excès à
la roche-joubert qui était présente sur
place et ça il y a un peu de faire
l'arbitre entre les deux sur place à
c'est pas bien passé elles ont même
évité de prendre l'avion ensemble pour
rentrer à Paris toute
dingue
selon mes infos c'est le Vitelli elle
est pas bien elle accuse le coup parce
que là elle se rend compte en fait que
quitter l'institution c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus fort que que ce
qu'elle imaginait elle a compris que
pendant le prime c'est pas elle qui
remettrait les chars ni la couronne à la
nouvelle Miss elle le prend pas très
bien elle est extrêmement vexée parce
qu'elle estimait que la passation de
pouvoir pour être un peu plus douce un
peu plus un peu plus amical au vu de son
service rendu on va dire donc elle
comprend l'IMP
c'était parce que c'était aujourd'hui et
c'est parce que ce sera demain
tout ce qui se passe
c'est pas pour vous chez vous mais là
avec ce qui nous a dit non
l'avion était attends c'est dans une
semaine c'est la première élection c'est
17 ans voilà elle sera que co animatrice
avec Jean-Pierre Foucault
révélation alors maintenant on va faire
8 mois après la claque will smithme
le ressenti Delphine en fait le truc
c'est que du coup Sylvie en fait elle a
un peu le syndrome de Geneviève de
Fontenay c'est à dire que elle pensait
partir elle pensait partir mais en fait
c'est sa vie et donc ça fait très mal et
Geneviève de Fontenay quand Sylvie
arrivé encore pendant des années on lui
a parlé de Geneviève Fontenay parce que
l'ancien est toujours mieux que le
présent en fait et je pense que tout le
monde
aussi que que Cindy aura pendant les
trois quatre prochaines années ce ce
peut-être ce déficit de légitimité mais
moi j'aurais adoré
c'est hyper
importants elle a beaucoup de de de
capacités
tu seras peut-être on la connaît pas on
la connait pas beaucoup
de paddley
Cyril c'est un programme c'est encore 7
millions de téléspectateurs à chaque
fois moi je suis au bout de ma vie
bon on a autre chose fait que deux infos
en fait parce que là
c'est quoi le retour sur le fiasco du
grand retour de Philippe winter ah bah
ça c'est alors c'est un article de pub
[Rires]
tu viens tu lis la presse
c'est pas bien ce que tu dis parce que
tu as pas écouté tout ce que je viens de
dire ça sur Sylvie Tellier
winter c'est un peu le bad boys on a
beaucoup parlé d'Ophélie Winter ces
derniers mois pour des mauvaises raisons
et là c'était censé être son vrai
come-back enfin on lui a confié les
rênes de de Dance Machine qu'elle
présentait dans les années 90 c'est une
émission spéciale très nostalgique comme
fait M6 depuis un moment et ça a été une
catastrophe absolue apparemment selon
les sources de public elle trouvait pas
ses mots elle elle déambulait d'une
façon un peu curieuse sur la scène elle
mettait mal à l'aise un peu tout le
monde sur les artistes les spectateurs
et et tous les services techniques qui
étaient sur place c'était une
catastrophe il a fallu refaire tous ses
lancements plusieurs fois c'est comme ça
je qui est présenté l'article et ce qui
était ce qui devait être son grand
retour à la télé apparemment
ça annonce comme un petit peu plus
compliqué que prévu
vous avez souhaité le meilleur à Ophélie
Winter elle revient bien sûr
Sylvie Telly
donc
toujours pas à toi tu es toi
c'est sa belle-sœur parce que tout
simplement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas je sais pas moi
je vous promets je ne l'ai pas vu j'ai
dit qu'elle m'appelle je ne sais pas bon
ok écoute ça me ferait plaisir qu'elle
vienne
on m'a offert une raquette de paddle
tu joues pas d'elle
[Rires]
tu veux dire un dernier truc ou bien
star rendez-vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est son grand retour il était caché
depuis 8 mois il a fait sa première
sortie publique pour un tapis rouge mais
quoi quoi c'est important il est revenu
présenter son film ah ouais savoir qu'il
a plus de projet il a été boycoté par
Netflix par Sony par ses paires par les
autres acteurs et cetera depuis cette
fameuse gif qu'on a vu on pense qu'on en
veut mais c'était une gif quand même
assez assez importante et là il revient
avec un film très important pour lui sur
lequel travaille depuis 3 ans et les
producteurs également ça s'appelle
émancipation ça parle d'esclavage etc le
thème est très très fort et il a donné
une interview cette semaine dans
laquelle il explique que il a bien
conscience que les gens vont pas
forcément regarder son truc mais voilà
il les encourage à le regarder parce que
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
travaillé sur le projet pour lui c'est
hyper important mais on est peut-être
voilà la question c'est est-ce qu'on a
envie que Will Smith reviennent aux
affaires est-ce que vous serez là
[Applaudissements]